new york city there we got a story out
of there with a retired high-ranking
nypd detective telling a harrowing story
of survival to 48 hours katrina cook
brownlee was attacked by her ex-fiancee
a corrections officer way back in 1993
she survived and became a cop herself to
change the system from within brownlee
talked to michelle miller for her first
prime time interview
in january 1993 katrina cook brownlee
riddled with bullets was rushed to this
hospital
katrina says she had already survived
years of abuse by her fiance alex irvin
a prison guard at rikers island i don't
remember
not having a black eye
it was always something
katrina says her calls to 911 always
ended the same way
and every time he would flash that badge
they would walk away
but there was no walking away from his
final attack he opened the door
and he pointed a gun to me and he shot
me in my stomach
and then he shot me again
and
[Music]
ultimately
he shot me 10 times
incredibly katrina not only survived she
focused on changing the system that had
let her down why did you want to become
a cop
i wanted to become a good cop there's a
difference
yeah a good cop has empathy a good cop
cares
katrina cook brownlee became a
top-ranked detective and one of the few
black women in nypd history chosen to
protect a new york city mayor
i was a great cop
wow and you can see michelle miller's
full report katrina brownlee the good
cop tonight at 8 eastern 7 central on
cbs news streaming network